Tell me a little bit about your dad.
Where do I begin?
You know, dads are dads.
Every good thing about me, it's come straight from my Dad.
Ever since we lost him, life has not been the same since he's been gone.
Music doesn't sound as nice,...
...food doesn't taste as good.
I just love him.
Thank you for loving me.
And I say I love him a lot that I cannot even count.
I can't even express how thankful I am for him.
I love very much, my dad, like everybody does, and I miss him a lot.
Sometimes I dream a lot about him...
...but he's done whatever he could for me.
There's that old adage, "it takes one to know one,"...
...and I realized that I was a good father because I had a good father.